entre deux âges portrait d'une jeunesse
documentaire réalisé par Clément Perrot
une jeunesse qui passe ici sa fin d'été
en bas des tours entre les immeubles et
les terrains vagues d'un quartier situé
en périphérie de Calais dans le nord de
la France avec ses tourments ses doutes
et heureusement ces espoirs l'occasion
de nous interroger maintenant sur les
aspirations de notre jeunesse dit
périurbaine avec nos invités présents
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de débat doc
avec vous pour commencer y a le aime
selem Maggie bienvenue à vous vous êtes
sociologue chargés de recherche à
l'Institut national de la jeunesse et de
l'éducation populaire votre daignier est
ouvrage s'intitule Les Filles du coin
vivrent et grandir en milieu rural et
c'est un ouvrage publié aux éditions de
Sciences Po Camille Penny est également
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes vous aussi
sociologue professeur à l'université
Versailles Saint-Quentin spécialiste des
inégalités social et votre dernier
ouvrage s'intitule lui pour une
politique de la jeunesse disponible au
Seuil dans la collection La République
des idées puis enfin avec nous quatre
Catherine Didier Faivre bienvenue à vous
et vous êtes géographe et chercheuse
associés au laboratoire environnement
ville société à l'École normale
supérieure de Lyon merci à tous les
trois d'avoir accepté notre invitation
on va préciser tout de suite que ce
documentaire que nous venons de voir à
l'instant a été présenté au Festival de
Cannes sélectionné à la Quinzaine des
cinéastes et il a été filmé dans le
quartier de fort niolet c'est ton
périphérie donc de Calais c'était un
ancien quartier ouvrier construit sur le
modèle des cités HLM que nous avons
découvert également dans ce documentaire
au-delà de cette jeunesse sur laquelle
on va s'interroger aujourd'hui
première question toute simple nous
l'avons vu ensemble ce film
en quoi il symbolise
la jeunesse dont nous souhaitons parler
aujourd'hui cette jeunesse dite
périurbaine on peut peut-être
s'interroger d'ailleurs sur sur ce terme
en quoi il symbolise les attentes les
aspirations les doutes et aussi les
espoirs de la jeunesse dont nous avons
envie de parler aujourd'hui alors
j'aurais tendance à dire qu'il ne parle
pas de la jeunesse en général mais peut
être d'une petite tranche d'âge dans la
jeunesse d'ailleurs les jeunes
interrogés se posent la question de où
il se situe où elle se situe sont plus
dans l'enfance ils sont pas encore des
adultes est-ce qu'ils sont vraiment
rentrés dans l'adolescence pour
certaines pour certains oui pour
d'autres bah il se posent la question il
y a des enfants dans ce film aussi et
donc ben c'est d'abord
des histoires de vie des séquences de
vie d'une partie de la jeunesse qui vit
effectivement pas dans un centre-ville
qui vit pas non plus en milieu rural qui
vit dans une cité d'habitat social qui
est pour partie en train de fermer on
voit qu'il y a des fenêtres qui sont
déjà scellées et donc on va suivre et
bien leurs attentes
rien qui caractérise aussi l'été pour un
grand nombre d'adolescentes et
d'adolescents puisqu'il faut passer ses
journées et discuter fait partie de on
va dire comment passer journée à ce
stage là quel sentiment que vous avez eu
en regardant ce film concernant cette
jeunesse dite périurbaine je sais pas si
vous êtes d'accord d'ailleurs avec ce
terme et ce que on parle bien d'une
jeunesse périurbaine dans ce film bah
alors moi j'ai bien cette région vous
avez passé une partie de votre enfance
oui toute mon enfance même enfin moi je
suis né dans le dans le Pas-de-Calais à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de
Calais plus dans les terres donc ça m'a
assez ému en fait de voir les jeunes qui
ne sont plus ma génération bien sûr mais
qui sont en quelque sorte la suite les
générations suivantes donc oui bah
Calais c'est une ville de taille de
taille moyenne si tu es juste au bord de
la mer et donc on a vu là effectivement
une frange de de la jeunesse alors
plutôt adolescente et moi ce qui m'a
frappé beaucoup c'est la manière dont
cet âge de la vie vraiment était un
temps de l'attente en fait les attentes
alors ils discutent bien sûr c'est l'été
il fait chaud on voit qu'il fait chaud
on voit que l'orage n'arrive jamais
vraiment on voit que la sécheresse est
là et ils attendent alors il parle de
l'amour il parle de plus tard il parle
de leurs aspirations et je trouve que ça
symbolise bien finalement que au-delà de
ces spécificités dont on reparlera mais
cette partie de la jeunesse cette partie
de de l'adolescence attend qu'il se
passe quelque chose et peut-être que
c'est en partie ce qui caractérise ce
qui caractérise cet âge de la vie et
puis moi ce qui m'a frappé par rapport à
mes travaux sur l'insertion des jeunes
sur leur mobilité sociale mais on en
reparlera c'est voilà un peu le fait que
on est un âge de la vie où l'on attend
où on se pose beaucoup de questions mais
c'est aussi des qu'ils auront repris
l'école en septembre à un âge de la vie
on va leur demander beaucoup de choses
très vite de faire des choix des choix
souvent décisifs et je trouve que cette
tension là qui est intéressante aussi
votre perception immédiate après avoir
vu ce film
si je reprends votre question sur est-ce
que on a affaire à des jeunes des
espaces périurbains pour moi c'est plus
un quartier périphérique de la ville de
Calais on arrive quand on regarde le
documentaire
j'ai hésité sur le terme périurbain
jeunesse périphérique on voit apparaître
ces termes vous seriez vous plutôt en
train de parler d'une jeunesse dite
périphérique non le quartier est en
périphérie de Calais Calais on en voit
rien on voit pas la mer alors qu'elle
est toute près on entend les mouettes
on a un peu l'impression qu'ils sont
prisonniers ce quartier coincés entre
l'autoroute
des centres commerciaux qui qui bordent
leur univers et
ça semble un peu compliqué de circuler
là dedans et encore ils arrivent à
passer
à pied d'un endroit à l'autre alors que
avec un véhicule ça serait ça exigerait
de faire un très grand détour donc ils
investissent des interstices dans ces
terrains vagues mais pour autant moi
c'est pas ce que je qualifie un espace
périurbain parce que on est encore dans
mon nez dans la continuité
urbaine de Calais et ce quartier est en
cours de
destructions à l'avenir on va passer un
premier extrait sur l'entre deux âges
que vous évoquiez il y a un instant
j'ai l'impression que je suis pas une
gamine mais je suis pas une adulte non
plus
quand j'étais petit je me posais pas
toutes ces questions c'était plus simple
maintenant il y en a qui sont en couple
ils ont leur vie de famille elles ont
des enfants
comment je m'occupe pas il y en a
beaucoup
voilà on en parle pas des garçons mais
enfin on en parle quand même enfin
évidemment ça fait partie des sujets qui
sont souvent abordés aux relations avec
le sexe opposé c'est vrai aussi pour les
garçons d'ailleurs qui s'expriment dans
ce film qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire de
concernant cette jeunesse est-ce que
c'est une spécificité de cet âge quel
que soit l'endroit où oui alors c'est
sûr que au moment de l'adolescence on se
situe par rapport aux autres donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit et là moi
toutes les enquêtes sur lesquelles j'ai
pu travailler avec des adolescents et
des adolescentes c'est vraiment cette
question de où j'en suis comment je me
positionne il y en a qui sont déjà
passés à l'étape d'après alors qu'ils
sont déjà en voie d'insertion
professionnelle d'autres qui sont des
consulter une classe et qui sont déjà au
lycée quand on est au collège d'autres
qui sont mais en fait tout ça ça va
servir aussi à voir où on en est et à se
poser des questions et comme elle dit
bien quand j'étais enfant je me posais
pas toutes ces questions mais aussi
parce qu'on invite moins les enfants on
leur impose moins de se projeter en
permanence et de devoir se positionner
sur un avenir qui se rapproche de plus
en plus et dire qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire où est-ce que tu veux aller tu te
rends compte tes parents encore en
couple et en même temps à reprocher dans
la même phase
[Musique]
bien sûr se situer entre les âges se
situer par rapport au rôle de genre que
la société cherche à lui assigner mais
aussi je pense se situer socialement je
fais l'hypothèse qu'à la commencer à
rencontrer aussi des jeunes femmes qui
viennent de milieux plus favorisées
qu'elles au lycée est-ce que cette
période de la vie s'est entre deux âges
on le vit différemment si on a un garçon
ou une fille en habitant dans ce type de
quartier est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous avez observé et si oui quel
serait les différences de vécues pour
ces jeunes ce qu'on observe c'est que
souvent les garçons sont peut-être plus
libres dans leur mouvement pour pouvoir
se déplacer avec les filles
avec des des mobilités
qui sont pas forcément explicités comme
étant interdites pour les filles mais
une espèce d'autocensure on peut parler
de mur invisible on va pas aller dans
certains endroits parce que on risque de
s'exposer mais
et puis c'est aussi une histoire de
réputation
alors que pour les garçons c'est
peut-être il y a moins cette c'est
surtout montrer les murs invisibles
c'est pour les femmes y compris dans la
ville
bon là on l'a on la voit cette jeune
femme toujours seule elle paraît peu
intégrée mais ce qui est intéressant
dans ce qu'elle dit c'est que son entrée
au lycée c'est vraiment une bascule
parce que je crois que le collège il est
cité il est situé dans la cité alors que
le lycée doit être peut-être dans le
centre-ville et c'est vraiment un moment
important au moment de l'adolescence à
l'entrée au lycée pour ceux qui ont la
chance de pouvoir poursuivre
parce que ça va être une rencontre avec
l'altérité
il a spécialité de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent elle est l'adolescent il a
une un champ beaucoup plus large ce
qu'on voit est-ce que ce qui est
intéressant déjà dans les images c'est
qu'on voit que des garçons en vélo il y
a jamais de fille en vélo qui circule la
seule fille qui a finalement un moyen de
mobilité c'est une poussette ce qui
rappelle aussi la manière dont on a
d'illustrer en permanence les rapports
de genre dans l'espace public les filles
elles marchent elles circulent elles
s'arrête pas elles sont pas posées les
garçons ils prennent la place finalement
y compris dans ce film y compris dans la
manière dont on a de raconter à ce
moment-là l'adolescence ce qui est
intéressant quand on va creuser sur les
manières de se projeter dans l'avenir
les manières de se construire pour les
filles et pour les garçons c'est que
finalement ils vont raconter elles vont
raconter
un bonheur commun qui est celui de la
conjugalité d'avoir une maison d'être
posée d'avoir un travail qui permet de
vivre pas juste de subvenir à ses
besoins mais de vivre une vie tranquille
et c'est il y a un moment il y a un des
jeunes qui veut dire et c'est ça le
bonheur et c'est ce qu'on va retrouver
dans les propos des filles et des
garçons même si pour autant il est elle
respiration sauf tout à fait simple un
bonheur simple
mais qui est pas toujours facile à
accéder de pas juste survivre mais de
vivre de du travail d'avoir une maison
d'être posée d'être tranquille alors
pour accéder à ce bonheur simple il faut
en passer par des études une ascension
sociale ou pas on a affaire à quel type
de classe sociale dans ce type de
quartier
c'est une ville populaire la cité est
habitée par des par des par les classes
populaires surtout une cité qui est
promise à la destruction on voit qu'il y
a déjà beaucoup de logements qui sont
fermés ou qui ont été qui ont été
quittés donc souvent ceux qui restent en
plus celles et ceux qui restent en
dernier dans dans un endroit qui est
pour mieux à la promis à la démolition
c'est souvent les personnes qui sont
parmi les plus fragiles et les plus
précaires donc on est je pense en
présence d'une frange populaire de la
jeunesse on voit pas du tout les parents
on voit pas d'adultes donc c'est un
parti pris j'imagine du du
documentariste on entend ce qu'on peut
imaginer être les parents rappeler à
l'ordre ou essayer de rappeler alors sur
une heure de de rentrer de rentrer à
l'intérieur mais on ne voit pas les
parents mais on est face à des jeunes et
c'est ça moi qui m'a frappé encore une
fois c'est on est face à des jeunes qui
sont probablement d'origine très
populaire qui probablement vont avoir
des choix d'orientation très précoces à
faire puisque plus on est d'origine
populaire plus on me demande de faire
des choix à précoce puisque déjà pour
suivre dans l'enseignement général après
le collège
c'est un destin qui est sélectionné
socialement tout le monde ne continue
pas au lycée général jusqu'au bac est-ce
qu'ils vont entamer les études
supérieures et ce qu'ils vont les
entamer
en l'occurrence à Calais parce qu'on
sait que on a affaire à des villes qui
ne qui n'offrent pas un choix
tel qu'il pourrait être dans les grandes
villes françaises
concernant les études supers est-ce
qu'ils vont seulement avoir accès aux
études supérieures et s'ils vont
seulement les tenter ces études
supérieures il faudrait faire une
émission entière là-dessus et on peut
faire que des projections qui sont un
peu des des a priori en fonction de ce
qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui on vient depuis un ou deux
ans de parvenir à 80% d'une classe d'âge
au bac si on prend l'obtention du bac
général c'est à peu près 46 à 48% d'une
classe d'âge là si on fait des
prédictions statistiques je pense que
peu des jeunes qu'on a vu vont rentrer
par exemple en seconde générale donc il
y a une possibilité de des études à
Calais il y a une université du littoral
il y a des IUT il y a des classes de des
sections techniciens supérieures donc
l'offre existe mais il y a ce à quoi
vous avez fait allusion des des
problématiques de poursuites d'études et
on sait que à partir du moment où les
trajectoires scolaires sont très
socialement marqués très socialement
situé on peut penser que peu de ces
jeunes statistiquement bien sûr peu de
ces jeunes risquent d'entrer dans
l'enseignement supérieur quelques années
plus tard et s'ils le font ils le font
avec
des frais qui vont probablement
augmenter ça veut dire pour certains de
leurs parents leur payer un logement
leur probablement des transports il
faudra partir de Calais probablement
pour alors si on envisage un temps soit
peu des études supérieures bien sûr
c'est une problématique de la poursuite
des études en milieu rural ou périurbain
c'est souvent la nécessité de devoir se
payer un logement dans la ville dans
laquelle on fait ses études et ça pour
ces familles d'origine populaire même
les bourses ne sont pas une bouée de
sauvetage suffisante pour lever ce
financier mais qui encore une fois mais
finalement pas le seul frein c'est un
frein qui se pose quand on est déjà
arrivé en terminale beaucoup ont arrêté
avant la classe de terminale alors vous
avez beaucoup travaillé sur le thème de
la mobilité d'ailleurs dans ce type de
d'espace périurbain mais cette fois en
Île de France et vous dites ces fameuses
espaces sont trop souvent présentés
comme un piège spatial en particulier
par les adolescents subissant souvent le
choix résidentiel parental autrement dit
la mobilité c'est un élément essentiel
pour l'émancipation de de cette jeunesse
dans les contextes auxquels dans
lesquels j'ai travaillé les jeunes
vivaient dans des maisons pas dans du
logement collectif et souvent les
familles étaient arrivées là pour
accéder à la propriété avec quitter des
ensembles de logements sociaux et ne
pouvait accéder à ça que
lorsque
on s'éloignant de la ville et
dans un piège spatial j'ai retenu cette
expression que vous avez repris
évidemment dans dans le cadre de cette
étude et de vos travaux ils sont dans un
piège spatial tel que vous le définissez
loin de la ville que vous avez pas
forcément des transports en commun qui
sont à disposition un quart scolaire qui
vous emmène au lycée ou au collège et un
le matin un soir avec des une amplitude
énorme
ça va être un peu compliqué de se
déplacer et finalement l'accès aux deux
roues qu'on aperçoit dans le film on
voit dans les premiers plans il y a des
motos finalement l'équipement de roue ça
exige déjà d'avoir un budget
et ce que j'ai vu moi avec les jeunes
avec qui je me suis entretenue c'est que
au moment de et encore moi
j'ai fait mon étude sur des jeunes qui
étaient scolarisés dans un lycée général
ou technologique donc il y avait déjà
passé tous les les seuils jusque là
c'est au moment du choix des études
supérieures que là il y a vraiment un
très gros différentiel ou le milieu
social entre en ligne de contient se
rajouter au contexte spatial parce que
si
les parents
[Musique]
mobilise énormément de leur budget pour
rembourser un emprunt ça va être très
compliqué de payer des études et c'est
pas la bourse s'il y en a une et quand
les deux parents travaillent fouillent
pas qui va permettre de partir et
souvent on va se tourner vers le BTS du
coin jusqu'à ce qu'il y a une étude qui
a été faite en Vendée par Sophie orange
là dessus qui qui montre que c'est un
choix
pas un peu un choix par défaut qui
arrange bien tout le monde parce qu'il y
a des transports qui sont organisés et
qui permettent d'accéder à
l'enseignement supérieur est-ce que dans
la tête de ces jeunes il existe cette
idée qu'il faut partir est-ce que c'est
d'une priorité d'occuper cet
environnement dans lequel ils vivent
pour aller vivre dans des grandes villes
pourquoi pas aller vivre à l'étranger
s'ils en ont les moyens partir quitter
ces endroits est-ce que c'est une
préoccupation forte de ces jeunes je
pense que typiquement les jeunes qui
sont dans ce documentaire la question de
partir elle s'impose à eux parce que la
cité elle est en train de fermer et donc
ils vont enfin le groupe va se retrouver
éclaté ils vont pas forcément se
retrouver dans les mêmes cités
d'habitation sociale dans les mêmes
zones d'habitation sociale il y en a qui
sont déjà partis donc cette question de
partir elle s'impose à eux d'une part en
plus après elle s'impose à eux par les
trajectoires de vie aussi des familles
de leurs parents des parents des voisins
et tout ça et puis il y a ce contrat par
le parcours parental par définition à
cet âge-là tous chez leurs parents a
priori on n'a pas on n'a pas d'éléments
c'est pas où est-ce qu'ils habitent mais
on va partir de l'hypothèse que tout le
monde habite chez ses parents enfin la
grande majorité habite encore je sais
pas un stage là et donc ils vont se
poser la question et d'ailleurs ils en
discutent entre eux et les filles en
discutant entre elles dans le film
est-ce que tu irais habiter jusqu'à
Boulogne non mais c'est beaucoup trop
loin et le rapport au trop loin en fait
il est socialement situé clairement on
voit bien que les classes populaires
n'ont pas la même le même rapport à
l'espace mais aussi ne se sentent pas à
l'aise de la même manière pour franchir
tous les kilomètres pour aller
finalement dans un territoire où il ne
connaissent ou elle ne connaissent
personne ou on connaît pas on ne
maîtrise pas l'univers social dans
lequel on peut atterrir et on va voir
que pour les jeunes plus favorisés de
centre-ville de très grandes villes on
va il va y avoir une injonction adulte
de leur dire il faut regarder vers
l'international tandis que les jeunes
qui sont dans des petites villes on va
leur dire il faut que tu regardes vers
la grande ville la plus proche ou un peu
plus loin c'est-à-dire qu'on leur
rappelle toujours qu'en fait ils sont
jamais à leur place et que c'est pas
vraiment normal de vouloir rester là où
on est et d'être bien là où on est et
donc pour autant dans les propos des
jeunes et notamment des jeunes filles il
y en a certaines qui disent clairement
qu'elles sont bien là où elles sont mais
par contre il faut qu'elles aient les
moyens d'être bien là où elles sont et
c'est là où intervient la question du
couple du travail pour dire mais en fait
c'est ça mon bonheur c'est juste d'avoir
ma vie tranquille et la vie tranquille
elle peut être en bas de chez moi vous
avez l'habitude
et à travers vos travaux également de
dire il faut en réalité pour cette
jeunesse
moins de familles et davantage d'État
est-ce que ça s'applique à cette
jeunesse périurbaine qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui alors merci de m'avoir lu
déjà quand je dis ça en fait je parle
vraiment des jeunes on va dire à partir
de 16 ans je dis 16 ans parce que c'est
l'âge de fin de scolarité obligatoire
donc là à partir duquel des politiques
sociales peuvent s'adresser aux jeunes
en tant que tel la saison on est encore
au lycée donc ça peut aimer on peut
arrêter l'école donc c'est pour ça que
quand on parle des jeunes du point de
vue des politiques publiques on parle
souvent des 16-25 ans là ils ont un peu
moins de 16 ans mais ce qui est certain
c'est que on voit bien dans ce
documentaire le poids en fait de
l'origine sociale du milieu familial
dans le destin qu'on peut leur deviner
alors encore une fois sans faire de
prédiction donc j'espère que certaines
seront démenties mais on voit bien
qu'effectivement si on ne laisse ces
jeunes là dépendre dans les prochaines
années uniquement des ressources de la
famille on voit bien comment on va faire
faire en sorte que les inégalités se
reproduisent et on disait au début qu'en
fait ce documentaire montrait que ces
jeunes avaient des aspirations
particulières qui étaient certes pour le
coup assez banal mais finalement assez
noble qui est celle de devenir adulte de
devenir indépendant de devenir autonome
et pour le coup je pense que on a
commencé aussi l'émission en disant que
les jeunesses étaient très diverses très
fracturés que l'un avait une petite
fraction de la jeunesse mais je pense
que ce qui unit les jeunesse c'est cette
volonté d'être
soi-même de pouvoir devenir ce qu'on a
envie de devenir et de devenir
pleinement citoyen pleinement autonome
et pour ça effectivement je plaide pour
qu'il y ait des dispositifs qui
permettent aux jeunes en fait d'avoir le
temps d'être jeune si je devais résumer
c'est ça ces jeunes ils ont besoin de
temps on voit les questions qui se
posent on voit les réflexions qui sont
les leurs cette espèce de de plage
d'attente un peu indéfini qui s'étend
devant eux et devant elle et donc il
faudrait que dans une société du 21e
siècle vieillissante par ailleurs on le
temps à ces jeunes d'être jeune parce
que c'est un âge de la vie auquel on est
confronté à des questions qui
nécessitent du temps et on sait pas
forcément ce qu'on veut faire c'est un
peu angoissant quel que soit le milieu
d'origine et donc oui je pense qu'il
faut aller vers des politiques publiques
plus ambitieuses qui permettent aux
jeunes d'avoir le temps d'être jeune à
Calais dans les grandes villes dans les
campagnes un peu partout il est en panne
la sauce sociale pour la jeunesse que
nous avons vu dans ce documentaire ou il
y a une forte reproduction sociale
s'aperçoit que lorsque l'on a été
habitué dès l'enfance à bouger qu'on a
les codes de la mobilité c'est beaucoup
plus facile de se projeter dans des
études dans un travail ailleurs de pas
de se confronter à l'altérité alors que
si on n'a jamais quitté son village son
quartier c'est beaucoup plus difficile
ça veut pas dire que c'est impossible
mais
il y a une forte reproduction et c'est
c'est ça qui
est assez
désormais parce que ça laisse peu de
perspective
bien sûr il y a des contre-exemples
et puis on peut aussi avoir envie de
partir à un moment pour finalement
revenir
ou
vouloir partir ne pas pouvoir partir et
finalement faire sa vie
comme ça
finalement qui nous satisface donc c'est
c'est une une période qui est quand même
compliquée parce que il y a des
injonctions on voit que la jeune mère de
famille elle elle est déjà engagée dans
un processus
sur le long cours les la première scène
avec les deux filles qui qui est l'une
propose qu'elle s'imagine avec un gars
de Marseille
il y a une grande part aussi de rêve
dans toutes ces conversations
et si on va loin on peut s'imaginer tout
le l'avenir qu'on veut sans forcément
alors justement vous avez prononcé le
mot et on leur souhaite c'est le rêve
cet espoir en l'avenir alors la censure
sociale c'est un élément déterminant
c'est sans doute pas le seul mais plutôt
espérer voir ces jeunes rêver et
qu'est-ce qui permettrait de les faire
rêver et voir ses aspirations aboutir
ces aspirations alors je pense que d'une
part pouvoir rêver c'est un luxe c'est
un luxe parce que ça nécessite du temps
ça nécessite des moyens ça nécessite une
moindre pression socio-économique sur
juste j'ai la possibilité de rêver et
pas de devoir aller faire un job pour
subvenir aux besoins de la famille parce
qu'on a quand même une partie importante
de jeunes des classes populaires qui
participent à l'économie familiale faut
pas se lever non plus mais du coup
participer économiquement finalement à
la famille c'est aussi avoir moins de
place pour rêver alors sans penser que
quand on fait on rêve on fait forcément
rien mais ça fait partie ça veut dire
qu'on a du temps donc je pense qu'il y a
un enjeu de classe et en même temps ce
qu'on voit c'est que les rêves sont
aussi proportionnées à hauteur de ce
qu'on peut faire et c'est des jeunes une
forme d'auto-censure semble-t-il
lorsqu'on lit différents articles
différentes sur cette jeunesse de type
périurbain il y aurait bah c'est pas
pour moi je veux pas pouvoir je vais pas
y accéder
voilà c'est une forme de réalisme aussi
ils sont pas non plus ils vivent pas
dans une planète qui est séparée de
celle du reste du monde et ils savent
aussi et elles savent aussi bien les
conditions matérielles d'existence qui
sont les leurs il et elles ont vu leurs
parents sans emploi et en emploi et sans
emploi et donc cette question de la
censeur social elle se pose mais en fait
elle se pose aussi d'abord pour
maintenir une situation il y a plus
l'espoir forcément de faire mieux
d'accéder à plus que ses parents que
déjà de maintenir un niveau de
subsistance qui permette de juste avoir
pas juste la tête hors de l'eau or une
partie des jeunes alors dans cela du
reportage je les connais pas mais moi
dans les filles que j'ai pu rencontrer
typiquement dans les filles du coin
quand on grandit avec des parents juste
à la tête hors de l'eau on espère juste
d'être un peu plus cool et que la fin du
mois s'arrête pas au début du mois on
est davantage peut-être dans ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la vraie vie concernant
ces jeunes que des jeunes urbains
qui ont peut-être plus de temps
justement vous disiez il faut du laisser
du temps à cette jeunesse quelques pour
qu'elle puisse about voir leurs
aspirations aboutir qu'elle puisse vivre
tout simplement ces jeunes là ils sont
dans la vraie vie très vite peut-être
d'ailleurs effectivement en payant une
partie du budget familial oui ils sont
la réalité aussi ils sont confrontés à
des questions économiques très
précocement après moi je sais pas trop
ce que c'est la vraie vie les jeunes
urbains qui habitent qui habitent dans
des quartiers qu'on dit quartier
populaire en Île-de-France ils sont
confrontés aussi à une réalité très très
brutale
de travail vous le soulignez bien sûr
vos travaux mais il y a une idée de rêve
pour les jeunes il y a elisé le rêve
c'est un luxe et évidemment c'est plus
facile de rêver quand les parents ont un
niveau de revenu élevé des niveaux de
diplômes élevés etc mais je me rappelle
d'un autre documentaire qui suivait qui
s'appelait les bonnes conditions je
crois qu'il suivait des jeunes bien
mieux pendant plusieurs années et on
voyait que eux-mêmes faisaient face à
une pression parentale terrible et dès
le lycée alors ils allaient au lycée
évidemment dès le lycée c'était qu'elle
prépare quel endroit quel métier il y
avait finalement une autre pression qui
ne les laissait pas beaucoup de place au
rêve non plus et c'est pour ça que moi
je pense pas utopique de dire que une
des questions que la société doit se
poser c'est de réfléchir à la manière
dont on peut laisser ces jeunes quel que
soit leurs origines quel que soit leurs
aspirations tout le monde ne souhaite
pas s'élever socialement je sais pas
d'ailleurs si la censeur social ça veut
dire quelque chose pour ces jeunes on
voit que ce qu'ils veulent c'est un
travail c'est une femme un mari un toit
donc c'est pour c'est une réussite pour
eux et je pense que pour pouvoir y
parvenir il faut vraiment qu'on
s'inspire des sociétés qui ont réussi à
penser des politiques publiques qui
permettent aux jeunes de prendre le
temps et vous pensez à quelle société en
disant cela typiquement aussi toujours
en exemple les pays scandinaves qui ont
des politiques plus généreuses et plus
universelles et qui vont accompagner les
jeunes en tant qu'adulte je vous donne
juste un exemple c'est que par exemple
en France on va considérer les jeunes
comme les enfants de leurs parents et si
on est de les étudiants par exemple
c'est sous conditions de ressources des
parents alors que dans d'autres pays si
on aide les étudiants c'est parce qu'ils
sont citoyens et on les aide toutes et
tous quel que soit niveau de revenus de
leurs parents donc voilà c'est de penser
des dispositifs qui soient universels
qui soient protecteur et qui permettent
aux jeunes de prendre un an pour
réfléchir à ce qu'ils veulent faire et à
ne pas considérer que si par exemple on
redouble une année au collège ou au
lycée on a déjà perdu un an ça je pense
que c'est très important vous voulez
rajouter quelque chose nous sommes là
toute fin de cette émission
non je pense que un des éléments qu'il
faut retenir quand même c'est la place
du groupe et la place du groupe de
copains à être copine aussi à cet âge-là
et qui est constitutif en fait dans tous
leurs propos alors on voit que les
parents apparaissent pas dans alors on
sait pas c'est pas du tout ou en tout
cas dans la sélection des moments
choisis mais en tout cas on voit combien
on se situe dans un groupe et donc on
est un jeune parmi les autres jeunes et
je pense que ça se retrouve dans les
propos des filles dans les propos des
garçons et c'est ça aussi qui va
permettre de savoir ce qu'on veut faire
ce qu'on peut faire ce comment l'autre
nous a permis de rêver parce qu'elle
avait où il avait trois ans de plus et
il ou elle a fait ça et ainsi de suite
et c'est aussi tous ces parcours là de
gens qui vont faire l'entourage faire le
commun qui vont aussi permettre
d'imaginer d'aspirer de rêver et de
penser à l'avenir pour ses filles et ses
garçons et ces jeunes qui sont
rencontrés dans dans ces quartiers à ces
tâches de l'adolescence sont des jeunes
qui vont se retrouver bien plus tard une
fois qu'ils sont dans leur vie d'adulte
ou alors tout ça est derrière soi et
aucune idée aucune idée impossible à
dire merci vraiment à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission
aujourd'hui après ce documentaire vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des badogs
sur Twitter merci aussi à Salm masali
qui comme à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission et puis je vous
donne tout simplement rendez-vous pour
un prochain débat doc et ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]